and then we saw steve will do it this
last weekend over in uh yeah
that was fun how was that it was cool he
came to my show i
went back up with the bucket list tour
he came oh nice he came to the show and
there's a portion of it where he you
know he walked up and he's like he's
like i'm going to buy some merch he said
i was like all right dude and then he's
like i want to buy everything
but a million dollars worth of merch
he bought everything and then when he
was paying he was like is there like a
tip button here and i'm like there's not
dude and i'm like god damn it why isn't
there a tip
he would just took me like 87 grand
i'll take you know i take chains or
watches whatever you want to give me he
was just like are you sure there's no
tip button here and he's like waiting
for me i'm like yeah
dude
but there is a lamborghini dealership
i know and i'm not like quick enough to
be like you know some sort of jive to
like oh no we can just do this but
custom work i was just like [ __ ] dude
yeah
i mean i watched your podcast with him
because i was i was also curious about
the rate at which he spends money
because it's really
unbelievable like it is and i mean it's
it's working like it's people love
watching his videos because they're like
what's he gonna buy this week yeah and
so it like kind of fuels the whole
ecosystem but it's unbelievable i mean
it's like
it's like irresponsible but it's it's
fun to watch i cannot lie that you're
like
it's such a [ __ ] fascinating thing
and
you look at david dobrik giving away
like cars every video like david
dobrik's print but david dobrik is so
evidently
calculated and strategic and whenever
he's giving something away it's
something that like
came from the sponsor anyway you know
like and it's super tied in like very
strategically to the sponsorship you
know so you know david dobrik is really
uh
you know kind of pro about it whereas
what makes steve will do it so
compelling is that he's just [ __ ] out
of his mind that like it's so clearly
not strategic and it's just it's
compulsive it's like how much is that
sure let's do it right [ __ ] it you want
one too great we'll get you too your dog
wants one we'll get one for her too i
think i think compulsive is a good word
for it and what i wanted to urge steve
will do it to do is watch this
documentary called broke okay it's a
documentary it's [ __ ] fascinating
about like how like such the
overwhelming majority of professional
athletes are who earn tens of or
hundreds of millions of dollars in their
career like are completely broke within
five years of their professional career
ending you know and like
so
when i saw it i was like oh my god i'm
never gonna delete this off my ipad like
i wanted a constant reminder of like
don't think that money coming in is how
it's always going to be yeah and and
then like
but the thing is
with steve will do it i wonder if that's
even applicable because he's making so
much [ __ ] money i know yeah but it's
kind of like what shaq said it's like
okay cool we made 20 million but you
didn't make 20 million you made 10
million right like i wonder tax time
happens is he's just like [ __ ] but is
that a write-off for steve like i gave
away like 3 million last year
[Music]
mike tyson's tax guy in the
mike tyson had a mansion for his tigers
next door
square foot mansion for them as their
cat house jesus christ i mean that's
just that's just smart money though
that's a smart person
yeah um i what i wonder is that like
my friend and fellow youtuber danny did
a video about
duncan danny gonzalez okay he did a
video about like the logistics of giving
someone a car
because it's right it's not just here's
a ferrari it's like here's a ferrari and
a [ __ ] ton of taxes that you have to pay
on this car and so a lot of people like
like all kinds of people who won game
shows got in serious trouble with the
irs because yeah because a lot of the
times it says like on you know like
giveaway rules and stuff like that if
you read the terms it's like you can't
sell it within the first month
so people go broke because they were
given this crazy gift and they can't
afford it yeah so i'm wondering like
steve giving these people ferraris and
stuff it's like the most expensive car
you can have
well what the aftermath of that is like
like is it under their name
is it under steve's name and they can
just drive it forever yeah
yeah i know what george clooney uh
i remember there's an article on george
clooney he he made like 10 of his
friends millionaires but he gave him a
million and then he gave him 300
thousand dollars on top of it to pay the
taxes on the million yeah i thought that
was pretty yeah that is cool i i've
heard that story
um
he like apparently took his
buddies out for dinner
at this place in in mexico and
it was like 10 of his best friends from
college or whatever this is right after
he sold casamigos
and he was like all right everyone i
want everyone to reach under the table
and there was an envelope with a million
bucks in there that's great yeah
man
that's uh it's like i would never
[ __ ] do that
i'm kidding
it's an awkward thing you know like like
money is is like an awkward thing and
it's like
well it's not i mean i can't picture
george clooney being awkward in any
situation
but like
here's a crazy thing that happened i
went out to dinner
with steve wozniak one of the
co-founders of apples
right and
of course the guy's [ __ ] rich because
he's a co-founder of apple
and uh
like when it came time for the check to
come
it's like
he just steve wozniak just pipes up he
says
since i picked the restaurant i'm paying
the tab
you know i'm covering the check and and
i just felt there was so much to that
because it's like
i felt what he was really saying was i'm
not
paying for dinner because i'm [ __ ]
rich
i'm paying because i picked the
restaurant and he it was important to
him it felt to me to make that
distinction
because it's his way of having
boundaries you know like and he didn't
want to like disrespect
anyone who might be like i could pay for
my own meal i was i was super impressed
by it like it was just it felt like
healthy boundaries and like and he said
it joyfully you know like i picked a
restaurant i love this place and that's
why i'm paying yeah
yeah i think for
uh george clooney was like listen i just
made 500 million like i'm
i don't care how much you guys make i
just want to give some he's like you
know that steve will do it you know
that's that kind of stuff
yeah how do you know about that because
that because that's the other thing that
makes it weird is when you draw
attention to it which that the george
learning thing how do i know that story
like yeah well i've heard the story too
but yeah did he tell people or did his
friends tell people right it's kind of
cool
he did it and he wrote the own article
about himself
no he yeah exactly oh you're saying like
who did he tell afterwards
i just gave my buddies like 10 million
bucks so
i hate those youtube videos where people
are like all right we're gonna go pay
people's rent and then they go
door-to-door and film how good of a deed
they're doing
it always rubs me the wrong way like the
artificial positivity the the good
samaritan [ __ ] for views
but then again at the same time it makes
people happy that's why that content's
popular yeah so like i'm a little torn
about it sure just look at it and watch
it and know that that guy is just doing
it for selfish reasons because it gets a
lot of views probably but even if it's
self-serving he also just paid those
people's rent like they're not
complaining they're like yeah i mean you
did that for yourself but also my rent
is now paid for the year so yeah it's
helping people but it is very
self-serving so i agree it's such a
paradox maybe they're right or not maybe
they should donate the money that they
make from that video to break even maybe
or something or they should
like take the money back
yeah
just so like you know there's not a
double intention there it's like no this
is just for youtube
[Applause]
after the cameras stop rolling yes
exactly yeah
all right i do all kinds of that stuff
like without ever even mentioning it
just want to put that out
same sound
i mean you wouldn't believe this so i'm
not going to mention it though but it's
like it's crazy
i'm curious about the app that you made
how long did it take you to make the app
and then i know there's two different
thoughts because you
what are you laughing at over here
[Laughter]
but other than that
i would never say this publicly
that's great it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude